hi everyone my name is Mark and I'm a
machine learning engineer in pinside and
today I will talk about future learning
few short object detection related to
detecting utility posts in from Google
street view images
okay let's go
so firstly let me introduce this guys
they are Wireless 2020 and with this
company we have made this project
possible so Wireless 2020 is a New York
based fiber Wireless and mobile
broadband consulting company that is a
consulting or a company so all over from
the world and as you understand we'll
talk a lot about like this wiring fiber
cables and other stuff so firstly let me
introduce couple of variables couple of
like key points that will help us
understand this project better
so first of all usually the wiring of
kind of electricity wiring TV
communication internet and other stuff
is happening in two ways first one in
the left picture is the way of supplying
wires through the underground so what
they do is they dig up some holes over
there they put wires there and with that
approach they Supply like towns with
electricity and stuff and the next
approach is having this utility poles
everyone has seen one in the streets
this in a right picture and putic wires
on the utilities and we dispose the
electricity and other telecommunication
cables and other stuff goes to towns and
cities
and you can imagine that doing
everything for the underground case it
will take it will be much more expensive
and much more time consuming because
every time if you want to supply new
wires you need to dig up those places
and put everything there and for the
second case you just go there's a
utility pole already installed you just
put your warnings on top of it and it's
much faster and less costly
let us also understand one more thing so
there are mainly two types of utility
poles out there so first one is like
t-pos they're called T because like
obviously there are t-shaped they have
these T hands and also s pulse as Paul
stands for like straight pose they uh
are kind of have similar
activity as people so they're just
missing this T shaped
shape
so what uh what the companies and what
Wireless is providing service for with
its wire wire Geo platform is let us
introduce telecommunication company with
Lancome let's say so waveline.com wants
to expand into another market and wants
to apply a supply wiring to these
locations so it has two kind of
opportunities to for expansion to
location a and location B so what's
Wireless do in case it is providing this
Telecom telecommunication company
information that location a has all of
these streets has like 20 percent of RL
varying which means that only 20 of the
streets have this utility poles and
location B has 75 percent of our utility
poles wiring RL wiring and based on this
information this
telecommunication company might decide
to do expansion on location B because
there are already utility boards posts
there and it is less costly to apply new
wiring and do its businesses there so
this is the main idea of their project
and they uh how they come up with these
percentages and stuff
so the manual process that was Wireless
doing is they have this kind of Google
Maps kind of files they are called KML
files and you can see like the red lines
over the streets so for each red line
they have like the coordinates of
latitude and longitude of the specific
location and where what they are doing
is they are going through each point and
they are like looking through Google
Street View Google Earth and manually
like a person is going and doing old
stuff they check whether there are
utility poles inside there and if there
is a utility border they start to
segment those areas so if there are
utility posts those streets are
considered as RL wire wired and if
utility poles are not present there it
is considered like underground firing
and with doing this they have
information of the percentages of that
specific Town having Ariel or
underground wiring and for the red ones
is like the places where street is
street view is not available or it is
quite difficult to see whether there is
pole installed or not I mean it might be
under the like in the back of trees and
stuff
okay so what we've done is we automated
this whole process firstly what's our
approach doing is we connect to Google
Street View API from this API we get
like the images for each specific point
that we had in the cam KML file and we
download like four pictures from them
front view back right and left and then
we construct a simple object detection
model through which we check from these
all images whether there's a utility
folder or not
so after that we construct the
camel file with all the information of
kilometers distances of this wiring and
similar to this file we get the output
of the segmented fragmentation in the
streets
now this is the whole process but during
this talk we'll concentrate on how we
build these object detection model that
is detecting utility poles from the
images
first of all let's talk about the data
we we are given like data of 2500 T
poles annotated data so and that's it we
have just that amount of images and
they're annotated what we can do we just
build the
object detection model which is
detecting the tipoles however there's a
huge problem in here
uh it turns out that in all our location
around the 50 percent of the poles that
are present there are as poles so if we
build just a model that is detecting
t-posts we'll miss 50 of the locations
that are uh have as posts installed and
now we need to somehow uh
solve the problem of the detection of
s-pos
one of the possible solutions to do this
is that first comes to mind is we just
calculate more data about the s-post we
annotated and continue training our
object detection model similar to T pose
however I mean this process is first it
is coming to first mind but it's very
not cool and very time consuming and
costly because imagine you need to
download all of these s-pole images you
need to hire people to do all these
annotations then check whether they are
doing annotations good enough because
models are heavily reliant on that and
also the worst thing is you just need to
sit down and wait when these annotations
are done in order to start modeling so
it is a long process and you don't want
to undergraduate and the solution of it
is using few short object detection what
is it it during that we only need 5 to
10 annotated images so far for S poles
and only having that amount of annotated
images we will be able to construct a
model that will also detect that kind of
pots
okay now I will talk about a little bit
a few short learning we'll dive deep
into few shot classification and then
talk a lot about few short object
detection so firstly let's Define future
learning is the task of solving a
machine learning problem with only
having limited amount of and annotated
data and we want to define the
simple through short classification
problem so here we have n y k short
classification problem and we have a
support set that consists of n-classes
labels and for each class we have K
labeled images also we have q query
images and we want to classify the query
images among these and classes so this
is the problem statement that we want to
solve with few short image
classification to be more visual to
understand more visual in a visual sense
so here like we have a
three trees no three-way two short
classification problem because we have
like three classes and for each class
like we have two images in there and the
query set is like images that are uh
corresponding to any class from the
support set so basically this is the
visuals of official classification
problem now uh I'm talking about some
support set and query set let's also
Define what are those in order to get
the full picture of here
so for future learning we have like
mainly three types of sets so first of
all first one is the base set base set
is like the big uh training data with
annotating annotating images of Base
classes so in our case the base classes
are t-posts we have uh 2500 annotated
images of t-pose then we have the
support set which are the few uh samples
of Novel classes or Support classes they
are called in both ways and we discusses
we want to fine tune our model to detect
to detect it so in our case it is the
s-pulse and the query set is the set to
evaluate our model
on our our function model and in this
case the set also consists of s pulse
okay so for the few short classification
there are mainly a couple of ways of
doing so I will talk to you about two of
them meta learning and Metric learning
during The Meta learning curious uh
what's happening there in the image we
have like two stages first first thing
is meta training and the second part is
Method testing during The Meta training
we take we initialize a meta model and
we take from base set kind of images and
constructed construct it in a way that
is similar to meta testing the support
system query so we have this kind of
episodes inside of them it is like
firstly sets a few short sets similar to
support set and the query set and the
training happening in a way that firstly
it starts training the base model in the
episodic way after each episode it
starts to fine tune the model on meta
testing on a support set and in the end
the
classification laws of the query images
is back propagated for The Meta model so
in this way the overall meta model
learns to clearly to initialize
parameters in a way that given like few
examples it would be able to quickly
understand what classes it belong and
transfer it to the query set
and the other approach is the metric
learning or all these net force is quite
similar to xiaomi's networks so for the
matching networks after having base
model trained on a base set we just
calculate the embeddings of support set
and query set images and start to
calculate like
the distance metric between them and
whichever like cosine similarity metric
and which whichever class is more
similar from query to support set we
classify it to belonging to that class
for the prototypical networks uh the
process is the same uh the only
difference is that whenever when I
calculate the embeddings they average
this embedding across the Support
classes and then compare with query
images these average embeddings with the
same distance metric and for the
relations relational networks everything
is the same however they get rid of
these cosine similarity distance metric
and let the model itself train uh its
distance metric and model during the
training model itself understand what
things to compare in in what way
and that is it about few shot
classification
now we come to the Future object
detection and what firstly it is
important to clear out all of the
differences between few short object
detection and few short classification
so firstly in the most important
difference is that we have several
object per image during this few short
classification case for each image like
we have only one object in that image
and we want to classify that specific
image having any class from the support
set and in this case we can have
multiple objects as object detection
thus multiple objects in a single image
and the important thing is that we can
have both the base classes and novel
classes in the same image like in this
picture our base classes are bicycles
and novel or Support classes are humans
there so we can have images that contain
both bicycle and humans in them and it's
important during the base training to
remove the annotations of
people from the from the data then start
training however we don't need to get
rid of the images that contain human we
just we use them during race training uh
however we remove all the annotations
there
the second point is join prediction on
base and novel classes uh what this
means is that during few short
classification usually they evaluate
make evaluation on novel classes only
they train the base model however after
fine-tuning evaluation is done only on
novel classes for few shot object
detection the evaluation is done both on
novel and base classes and the idea is
that we help the model during evaluation
not to forget information about the base
classes that it learned during his
training and so after fine-tuning the
model contains both information for the
base classes and novel classes and if
there's an image that contains these two
classes we will not like forgetting
anything about the basements and we are
detecting both people and bicycles in
the image and the last thing is learning
to learn we see fine tuning as you
remember during future class application
episode like learning was used so from
the base set we constructed the episode
similar to the support set and query set
and then trained for each episode after
fine-tuned on the supports and
evaluation and query set during few
short object detection it is not done in
this episodic learning way firstly they
fine tune the whole few short object
detector base model on the whole base
classes and then firstly train on base
classes and then they fine tune it only
support set for once and later they give
evaluation for both based classes and
Support classes these are the key three
differences between future object
detection and classification there are
like many modes but these are the ones
that we need to consider
uh for sure
and already we came to the point of what
approach I used for the
solving this problem it is called
frustratingly Simple few short object
detection it used the two-stage fine
tuning approach as you can see there are
two stages the base training and few
shot fine tuning during the base
training as I already mentioned uh the
models initiated model which in our case
is faster rcnn is trained on the base
training data set fully with this
training we help the model to get to
extra to learn how to extract good
features from the images from Beach we
will later
use this feature extractor part in the
fine tuning stage and for the second
stage as you can see the blue shaded
area here is our future extractor we
freeze the future extractor during fine
tuning and we randomly initialize
weights for box classifier and box
regressor and start to fine-tune on the
support set so to sum up this part we do
the base training on the base model on
base classes we fixed the feature
extractor and initialize new weights for
box cluster box aggressor and do the
fine tuning on the support side
it is quite simple hence the name for
starting a simple few shot object
detector
so kit takeaways from this paper were
that they wanted to achieve the
separation between between the future
representation learning and box detector
learning that's why it is kind of
two-stage process and they achieve it
with doing this kind of training during
the fine tuning they lowered the
learning rate around around 20 times so
the model converges on the support set
better and it is interesting the
training that the feeding approach they
described it in order to have a better
fine tuning it is beneficial to use
images that contain both base and
Support classes in the same image in
that way model better understands the
differentiation factor between the base
classes and novel classes so whenever we
are doing fine tuning for 10 or 5 shots
we need to make sure foreign
I suppose present in the same image
okay now let's let us see the results of
uh doing this training on 10 shots only
meaning we have just 10 images for the
uh of annotations of s poles so the left
picture contains
um
prediction of Base training after the
base training on tripos model only
identifies the tuples and after 10 shot
fine tuning we see that monster model is
capable of understanding that there are
also as poles in the same picture
uh here's another result there
left one is base model and the right one
is fine tune model
and also one more example
and basically with this uh
I end up
um like or I saw we kind of solve our
problem of identifying detecting what
kind of poles available
a couple of words about the deployment
so we used Google compute engine to
deploy this model into the production we
took a virtual machine with the specific
specifications and
we use the Nvidia Tesla T4 GPU for the
influence in production and it was
around monthly 260 dollars cost if it's
constantly running in the cloud
uh what are the other plans that we can
use to solve these problems or for
future works first of all it's quite
important the selection of shots many
papers say that one of the important
things here is the selection of training
data set is the correct augmentation
other stuff so here we can achieve
better results if we choose different
shots there we need to kind of hand pick
better images with better positions of
in our case poles so both to have t-pos
and test pulse in the same image so a
selection of data is very important in
this kind of meta learning and fusion
detection cases and the other approach
is using like self self-supervised
approaches such as that track
what is the main differences that during
the base trading and training in in this
case we don't even have annotations for
the base classes so we have just images
of I don't know a lot of images of T
balls and espos but we don't have
annotations and these models help to
kind of get features from these images
and using in self-supervised approaches
and only after that we get like a couple
of annotated images for both base
classes and novel classes in our case
both these are becoming like novel
classes and we only fine-tune with them
so firstly train the base model with
self-supervised
approach and then only fine tune with
the novel classes there
okay basically uh this is what I plan to
talk about today uh so thank you for
coming if you have any questions you are
welcome and you can find me in LinkedIn
here
[Applause]
thank you for presentation uh I have a
question about fine tuning uh what model
do you use for fine tuning okay so for
the object detection I faster our CNN is
used both for base training and fine
tuning and this first part here of the
faster Arsenal is Frozen for the fine
tuning stage and box detectors
classifier and reversers are randomly
initialized and then fine-tuned okay
thank you and second question like
infusion learning Fusion object
detection
uh in generally what is the percentage
of labeled data or like you say 510 but
what is the overall amount of data like
ten thousands or what is typical amount
of yeah okay thank you for the question
usually when we talk about future
learning we just mean having uh one two
three five and up to ten labels and if
you have like uh 10 000 of images of
annotations then it most definitely
definitely will work better than just 10
shots but in real life scenarios usually
we don't have that kind of
so the precise answer is we have a lot
of data then do like the normal training
it would get for sure better results but
in case of small amounts then you apply
for short learning okay thank you
this
is
thank you thank you for
we are very interesting speech and my
question is the usual practice uh tell
us if you have a very small amount of
data use augmentation
did you use augmentation
um
in our specific case no but yeah I was
talking about that over here that
selection of shots and augmentation is
quite important in this case in overall
cases all of the papers say that in case
of missing data augmenting it and having
multiple of them it would be a help but
in this case we don't do any specific
augmentation here
the thing is I tried with this and it
gave like okay issue results and I
didn't go further for the augmentation
yeah thanks
[Applause]